hello everyone and welcome to another
google+ hangout i'm excited to have with
me Kevin Cruz who is a serial
entrepreneur he's an author he's built a
number of different businesses he's an
angel investor and I'm going to ask him
about how he got started his lessons and
some advice for entrepreneurs and
welcome to the show Kevin thanks having
great to be here been following your
stuff for years i'm honored to be on the
show so for people who may not be
familiar with you yet can you give
people a little bit more of a background
about who you are which all about yeah
sure I am well I I live outside of
Philadelphia in Bucks County
Pennsylvania got three great kids and in
the past had you know started a series
of different tech companies primarily
online learning and education companies
some that did well others that that
didn't and since selling my last
business I guess almost about six years
ago now that's really when I did a
personal pivot and have spent a lot more
time you know writing books doing talks
doing board work nonprofit work and
things like that great what Tom for
entrepreneurs who are starting up so i
started in tech too and I'm i gotchu you
guys had a seller transition where I'm
you know helping entrepreneurs out what
what prompted that change what prompted
that desire to you know so you sold and
then instead of saying hey I'm going to
go smoke another tech company I want to
give back and start helping
entrepreneurs what what led to that
realization yeah and you know that's a
that's a big question of them because I
think entrepreneurs it's almost like
it's almost like we have a genetic
defect I have a friend who calls it a
genetic defect where we just over and
over again and uh you know to be candid
it was a point in my life where I done
so many and doing that entrepreneurial
grind I think I was a little tired and
burnt out I've got three great kids
still all in school age and thought it'd
be a great time to you know be dad first
and start to give back a little bit and
just you know focus on a quality of life
that was
a little different than the than the
entrepreneurial grind but but I gotta
say I mean it's been over half a decade
of leaving that game and that it doesn't
go away you know so I've been able to
scratch it a little bit by advising
entrepreneurs encouraging them doing
some investments but it's not the same
as a betting on yourself and going all
in so I don't know another year or two
I'm comin yeah baby he's got it cool uh
what what what advice do you commonly
give so I mean you're investing in
startups you're investing in companies
your your you know giving them advice on
how to grow what are some of the common
issues that you believe are important to
help entrepreneurs get past those early
stumbling blocks yeah i mean i think
that when i get involved it is early so
I think there's different lessons and
different things to to know at different
stages um you know I'm uh working as an
executive coach a startup coach to a
non-profit education company in Pakistan
right now for example is an American guy
who's in Pakistan and has started this
venture and it's a great case of
tremendous you know intelligence ideas
enthusiasm put in his own you know dent
in the universe and where I can add
value is and where you know some of his
questions are is everything from the
business standpoint of you know focusing
on on the things like culture mission
vision values and things that sometimes
feel like boy I'd rather debug this code
or go call that customer but ultimately
are very important in the long run and
at the same time you know I encourage
entrepreneurs to really speak to someone
just so they can have some balance and
focus in their own life I mean it's
something I missed I mean it's it's do
what I say not what I do because I was
just focused on the business and doing
that classic seven-day workweek around
the clock runnin and gunnin and it can
take a toll on you you know mentally
physically and now with hindsight I
realize you're
not in the best place to be thinking
creatively and with innovation and
you're not gonna be able to coach those
around you when you yourself are burnt
out and depleted so you know when i'm
working with entrepreneurs now young
younger newer entrepreneurs you know
half the stuff is about the business but
the other half is really about just life
and ultimately that all there is it's
it's all the same thing right Saul as
goes the leader goes the rest of the
company and you really need to be
holistic about that as well how are you
I'm curious so what you know you got
that itch you want to scratch it in the
year we'll see how long it lasts until
you could die back in how are you going
to manage that now you have a wife you
have kids you know that they're growing
up how are you going to manage that
grind in your next startup so that it
doesn't take such a huge toll on you
personally well it's even worse than
ever because I have the kids but I don't
have the wife I'm a single dad so okay
there you go so any given day I'm you
know making peanut butter jelly
sandwiches or taking someone to you know
check out a strep throat or a school
thing or whatever and I think that's
part of what's kept me on the sidelines
for a while but I also think you know
with some some experience comes some
wisdom and realizing that you know you
you don't have to do it all yourself I
mean that was my big it was like a light
switch went off I mean my first company
I was 21 years old and and thought I was
you know doing that startup grind but I
thought I had all the answers I was
selfish I didn't want to share equity I
didn't want to pay people well and I was
out of business and in debt in one year
and the second business I had a partner
that's you know in a step in the right
direction and yet didn't know how to
fight constructively didn't know how to
communicate constructively didn't know
how to you didn't think I needed a board
of advisors of board of directors
mentors even um and that lasted about a
year this time not in debt but but
decided as isn't working out and it was
really the third fourth and then
eventually even fifth businesses where I
just realized okay you know find the
best talent I can in a given area let's
say it's marketing let's let me find the
best marketer but don't pretend I have
all the answers and even if I do have
some of the right answers because of my
experience or insights or whatever
realize that every time I change
something or step on that territory I'm
disengaging that person it becomes my
company not their company my project not
their project and so when you hire great
people if you then just don't focus on
their domain area that focus on creating
a great culture of engagement they're
going to give you you know all the hours
you would ever want that we they're
going to give you the best talent
they're going to own their mistakes and
learn from them and I realized with that
third business that went well I sold it
after about five years thought ah you
know I need to really focus more on this
talent in culture piece and the next
business I spent more time on that so
that company didn't even better the last
one I did one thing I said okay i'm the
founder CEO let me hire great people and
make sure the culture supports them I
mean I didn't get involved you know
directly in sales marketing products I
mean I had the vision I set it up and
then it was all about assembly two great
team and that that business it was Inc
500 business one best place to work
Awards the less I did myself in the
business the better it did so this is a
long way of saying that I hope that if
indeed I would ever jump back in the
game in a big way I would have that
wisdom and realize you know I I'm going
to be pushing 50 I've got kids I'm not
working 80 hours a week I'm not going to
go out on every single sales call I'm
not going to debug that code myself you
know it's going to be more about
hopefully having a clever idea and some
some mission vision and values but it's
about attracting partners not being so
selfish attracting a great board of
advisors a great board of directors um
be willing to who raise some money I
always bootstraps I was too selfish to
to raise money you raise money not for
the money you raise money because now
they have access to their network and
whether that's for beta customers for
chief
officers whatever you share out that
equity to get that expertise and evident
could all be smoke I mean I could be
wrong but I think I just be a lot
smarter about doing it and hopefully a
lot saner you have interviewed some
amazing people and you probably see what
I see is that you know the higher up the
more successful people are it's almost
like the calmer they are the less
frantic they are you know I I anyone who
i knows had any kind of you know
material success in life or professional
success in life they're not running
around you know with a to-do list and
ranking A's and B's and let me fit this
in that's not how they run their life so
I had that all wrong when I was in my
20s and I think I'm going to be a little
bit wiser about that that balance you
know moving forward so if you were to go
back and I mean even now I mean you're
talking to the 21 year old kevin cruises
who are watching this show who you know
may not have access to capital they
haven't built and sold businesses they
don't have a huge Network ah and they
want to avoid the mistakes that you made
of trying to do everything yourself but
they're saying hey I don't have the
money to go out and bring these guys on
and I don't have a network what what do
you tell that 21 year old next Kevin
Cruz yeah I think that um here's I mean
the fur the most important message which
is great if they're already in the games
get in the game I mean it's never been
easier to be an entrepreneur to scale I
mean you think about so many of these
startups that are successful these days
with four or five six people that are
serving 400 million customers or in the
case of an Instagram or whatsapp you
know they've got 50 employees and
they're servicing 500 million people and
selling for a billion dollars I mean
it's never been easier yeah back in my
back in my day you know if I wanted a
SAS software solution I was racking and
stacking servers in the closet and I
used to have to do that and it's all
this money you know up front in these
servers not knowing if you're ever going
to really have traffic for them now you
know you read
for pennies you know from from ATMs on
AWS or or somewhere else with fiber with
with freelance calm with outsource you
know you can get a lot with not a little
money but the most important thing is if
you've got a great idea and are
passionate about it I mean people are
ignited by your passion or your
enthusiasm it's contagious so even if
you just have that good idea in that
passion you'll find people to work with
if you want to and you'll find money if
you want to um I am astonished I i I've
kind of um I've kind of young I'm not as
positive about angel investing as I used
to like I don't as an angel I don't it I
don't think it's all that I thought it
used to be but I'm amazed when I go into
these eight angel group meetings for for
rich men and women that are in these
meetings it ain't hard to get their
money i mean it's it's like betting for
them there's not a whole lot of due
diligence involved you know and these
days even venture capitalists i mean
they will fund a great ID in a napkin if
you're you know with with the right
people so a 21 year old kevin cruise or
Evan or anyone that's out there first of
all go for it it's never been a better
time to be an entrepreneur and don't
worry about not having that money i mean
yeah work hard hustle as much as you can
but then you know attract go find a head
of sales and give them ten percent of
the company and options go find a chief
technology officer give them ten percent
of the company options go talk to angel
investors and be willing to do a
convertible note or something yes you're
giving away some of your company but you
might get some resources in return it's
easier than ever before you have an
interesting philosophy that not a lot of
entrepreneurs will take in that you you
really want to share the share the
wealth and give up equity to get money
and to get people on board how do you
how do you prevent uh how do you prevent
giving it to the wrong person you know
how do you make sure that that CTO
you're giving it to
young giving them ten percent how do I
know you know I'm that 21 year old kevin
cruise how do I know that the guy I'm
giving that money to or that percentage
in is is going to be the right person
help me build this thing long-term that
that's a powerful question because even
the people who specialize in you know
how to select great talent they'll admit
that their success rate is fifty-fifty I
mean there's it's really hard to get
great people so I mean ideally you're
working with people that you're bringing
in people as partners who you've worked
with in some capacity mess and they're
already a known entity if you can't do
that it's great if you can bring people
in on a trial basis or a project basis
um if you can't do that then of course
what you do is you set up the contracts
so that it's it's it's all earned so
let's say you know Evans the CTO for me
definitely deserves ten percent of the
company but I'm not going to give it to
you on day 1 i'm going to say okay it's
either a third each year for three years
so if this doesn't work out after a year
and we part ways I've kind of limited my
downside or even to take more risk out
of it you make some you make some
deliverables you know some mentions and
whether that's around revenue or
installs or contingent on other raises
or whatever that might be you can have
clauses in there that would trigger an
accelerated earnings for that talented
person or you could claw some of that
back it those conversations always feel
hard because you want to just assume
that of course it's going to work out
you know it's kind of like prenuptial
agreements in marriages right you know
you don't really want to tell the person
who you love and are gonna of course in
the rest of your life with oh but what
if it doesn't work out I mean it's a
horrible conversation to have more and
more people are having these kinds of
conversations so I think it's the same
thing is do everything you can to make
sure that especially at a partner level
that you found the right person but then
as much as possible make that ownership
contingent on success
got it and as an angel investor what are
some of the things that you would look
for in a pitch that's coming to you yeah
you know I I've seen a lot of them I've
changed a little bit on that I mean what
always looks great is when when the
entrepreneur has has done it before so
you know it's someone who had a key
position at a certain company so you
know they've got some experience you
know they've got some some some
connections and things and they're going
to do it again on their own in some way
this is sort of a repeat or even if it's
a different area but they specially
started and sold a previous business at
least you know they know how to raise
money they know how to hire people they
know how to talk to customers again you
know anything it's a bettin bet not a
jockey that's once in previous races is
is the easiest way that's hard that
doesn't happen that often though so when
I have invested I mean I certainly would
like to believe in the idea and I end I
need to hear that passion from the
person I need to know that I mean
they've got a vision for this future
that is is going to happen and lastly
though I don't want to get involved
unless I can add value um I can't
remember who said it originally but they
say you know great opportunities are
like buses they just come every hour and
it's true i mean you can you can go on
to you know angel list or an any angel
meeting or whatever there's hundreds or
thousands of deals i get i get
unsolicited pitches through linkedin
three four times a day from people great
ideas but um you know if it's a great
idea someone I don't know and not an
area I can contribute to yeah another
bus is going to come around in an hour
I'm not too interested and there's a lot
of ways to lose money in the startup
game and as an angel if someone came to
me though and said hey Kevin you know we
sought you out as an angel not just
because you can write a check but we
know you had this success building and
selling elearning companies especially
in the life sciences space well we've
got this new I
for a mobile learning platform we've
already got this pharmaceutical company
on board as a beta and we know with your
connections your experience in the space
you can add value your smart money not
dumb money that's something that's very
interesting to me um and then Evan I
know you would know this but but just to
also share that this at this point I say
no to a lot of deals just based on
valuation valuations are through the
roof right now I mean it's crazy it's
really crazy so when someone comes to me
with an idea on a napkin basically and
and and they do and they say so we're
raising a million dollars and the
valuation of the company is 10 million
dollars so you're going to get you know
ten percent if you write the million
well you start doing that it's like
first of all if I'm only writing a
hundred thousand i'm not getting temps
on getting one percent and you see how
much influence you're really going to
have in that company is quite small as
an angel um but but there's so much risk
even in well-run startups I mean it's
just it's really hard and for companies
with no revenues at all to be asking for
10 million dollar valuation and they do
all the time I mean that's good luck and
they probably will find money from other
people but ain't gonna be my money so
how do you value a start-up you know
it's a lot easier when you have revenue
and customers and you you've got that
first you know those first deals and you
can you can play and say hey we're going
to keep growing like this but somebody
comes to you with an idea a napkin and
say hey I think I can make tons of money
but i haven't sold anything yet what do
you say do you say still try to raise
money to say hold off until you get some
customers how do you evaluate that
business well I mean the this the second
question about do they hold off or not
you know I'd say no I mean I think right
now if valuations are high people are
getting it and so I would actually say
if you at all think you might want to
raise money go out and raise it now
because you're going to get a much
higher valuation just because there's so
much venture capital money angel money
and all these new
millionaires in Silicon Valley they're
all bettin just like you know at a
casino they're betting on things now's a
great time to raise money at a high
valuation but how do you value a company
that's tricky and you're right um it's
it's kind of funny once you have a real
company with with revenues and profits
people want to value you based on a
multiple of your profits so you know if
you're a slow growing company or a
professional service firm you know might
be a five times profit or a seven times
profit if you're a tech company you're
going to get a lot more than that or
maybe it's a couple times revenue the
challenge is win your brand new but the
opportunity is to sell the dream this is
a this is a true story i'll keep it i'll
keep it short but many many years ago I
was working at a company in a
partnership and we were uh we had we had
raised venture capital and we were going
out and getting pitched and investment
bankers were going to go public and we
are talking about this valuation issue
and so our venture capital partner said
are you need to come up with a brand new
you know five year plan detailed PL that
you're going to show everyone your path
to revenues and ultimately profitability
so the team went back and worked like
around the clock for weeks on this thing
spreadsheets models all this stuff right
up to the wire we fly up the Boston we
meet with our venture capital partner
it's midnight the net the pitch this
pitches start the next morning he looks
at the RP & L's and he said oh you guys
messed up he's I guess I wasn't clear
there's a problem here what's the
problem he says you show you're going to
be profitable in year four well yeah we
thought people would want to see how
they're going to get their money back to
really profitable eases no no as soon as
they see profit they're going to bring
the multiple down you need to show
losses through your first five years so
you can sell the dream I don't make that
this is sounds like a Hollywood movie
Midnight we said well he says you need
you need to lose 50 more million dollars
well what are we going to spend it on
like we
already calculated all we're not going
to spend 15 ounces oh no it's easy just
put it in marketing at midnight we
increased the marketing budget by 50
million dollars over five years tank it
to the P&L two losses and then went out
and told this story about how huge we
were going to be but you can't value us
on profits so you know it's whatever you
think we're going to be the opportunity
is and that's where the market just
speaks i mean right now if you've got a
SAS software company you know startup
idea you're going to go out and you're
going to get 10 million dollar valuation
from somebody if you bang on enough
doors you know a year ago that was maybe
a five million dollar valuation for
years ago maybe you would have gotten a
two and a half million dollar valuation
same idea same same startup team it's
just the supply and demand of who wants
in on that deal so from our standpoint
ask for everything you can but
unfortunately there's no real good you
know logic or math how do you value a
start-up that's got no customers yet no
revenue yet to speak of it's what people
are willing to pay whatever they're
willing to pay my friend Kevin thank you
so much for spending some time with us
today for people who want to learn more
about you and read your books and find
out what you're doing next where can
they go I appreciate that I'm just
website is Kevin Cruz com that's Kevin
then KR u SE kaam and i also have a
entrepreneurs journey manifesto that's
out there just Google entrepreneurs jury
manifesto and they'll find it awesome
thank you so much Kevin I really
appreciate your time and and the passion
and the love that you have for
entrepreneurs hey thanks for what you're
doing for Astra nervous thanks Evan
cheers